Coach, ​t​hese plays are from before they invented the forward pass.
Why is every guy on our team 40 years old?
I'll tell you what man, you modern players with your personal brands and your screen passes.
Sometimes I wish I could just go back in time, man. Ooo-
Thanks for paying for the time machine instead of Khalil Mack.
Oh, of course, Jonnie! I love chasing the past!
Bring me back to when football was football and men were men, man.
2002!
Same office, same haircut
Wait... I know you man.
Coach, it’s me, Rich Gannon.
I tell yah what, a reliable quarterback I don’t have to pay...
I went back in time, man!
Hey, Coach Gruden!
Clean tackle!
Can’t wait to practice all offseason with no restrictions!
I am in heaven!
Oh hi, Coach! Have you met our terrible backup yet?
Hello. I’m Thomas-
Whoops!
Hahaha, thank goodness for the Tuck Rule.
Even clumsy rookie idiots can drop the ball...
and it’s still not a fumble!
MARK, YOU GOT TO BRING ME BACK TO 2018, MAN!
Tight Ends who block, Shrek, commit to the run game...
I’m sorry: But his brain is trapped in 2002.
FOREVER!
And that’s the Raider way!